after 33 years on late-night David
Letterman gives a candid interview to
vulture about his life in retirement
which includes a rather impressive beard
rendering him nearly unrecognizable
looking back at his career Letterman
reflects on times when he was a little
too hard on guests of the Late Show
quote many times the laughs would come
at the expense of the guest I regret
that now but at the time you think I've
got to do anything to keep my head above
water don't I always behave except at
one time when I I quizzed you about
being in prison yeah specifically
recalling his 2007 interview with Paris
Hilton when he brought up her jail time
after she violated her probation for a
DUI quote that upset her and she cried
and I called her and apologized I think
I bought her a car too as for his life
now Letterman is focusing on being a dad
to his 13 year old son Harry quote the
universe of worries and anxieties that I
possessed with regard to my son's
welfare seems to be infinite
[Music]
you